Apple has just released their brand-new
20/20 iPhone SC and I'm fully convinced
that it will be the best-selling
smartphone in the world but before I get
into explaining the four different
reasons why it's very important to first
know all the specs and features that
it's packin so let's quickly go through
them the design is basically identical
to the iPhone eight so that means you're
getting wireless charging touch ID and a
single camera the only difference is
that the Apple logo moved to the center
of the back it comes in either white
black or product red and it's priced at
a massively low 399 dollars for 64
gigabytes of storage which is $300
cheaper than the iPhone 11 and you can
pay just $50 more for double the storage
it gets a 4.7 inch Retina display with
326 PPI so it'll look just as sharp as
the iPhone 11 but the biggest news is
that it packs the same a 13 processor as
the iPhone 11 pro but with three
gigabytes of RAM so you're getting
literally the fastest smartphone ship
ever made in a $400 phone that's just
insane even better you're getting
basically the same incredibly good 12
megapixel camera as well with the same
generation smart HDR 4 photos in the
crazy part is that you could use
portrait mode on both the front and the
back with all the same features like
portrait lighting and even depth control
for background blur it even choose 4k
60fps video just like on the 11pro
except for one difference
you only get extended dynamic range at
up to 30 fps instead of 60 like on the
11 Pro this means that it's not getting
the same new Sony sensor the sensor is
probably from the iPhone 10 s but thanks
to having the latest software and 813
chip camera performance should be just
as good as on the iPhone 11 the most
impressive part is that Apple is going
all out with the other specs as well
including Wi-Fi 6 Bluetooth 5 with audio
sharing gigabyte LTE with 2x2 MIMO dual
SIM for having 2 numbers on the same
phone ip67 water
distance and fast-charging support if
you use the 18 watt charger now if you
plan on buying the iPhone se but you
don't have one of these fast chargers
we're gonna leave a link to a very good
alternative down in the description so
with all those specs out of the way
let's get into the four reasons why the
2020 iPhone se will be the best-selling
smartphone in the world first of all
both the iPhone 10 are in the iPhone 11
were the two best selling smart phones
in the entire world in 2019 why because
they were the cheapest iPhones you could
get while also packing top-of-the-line
processors and cameras and now with the
new iPhone se it's only four hundred
dollars while also getting the best
processor in any smartphone and an
excellent camera as well so for this
reason alone there will be a lot more
people choosing to buy this $400 iPhone
instead of going with a cheap Android
phone now if you're in the States this
deal sounds pretty nice but what about
the rest of the world well because of
the lower starting price the new iPhone
se will be even cheaper in other
countries that are hit with tariffs for
example in India the new iPhone se
starts at forty two thousand five
hundred rupees which is five hundred and
fifty-five US dollars a hundred and
fifty five dollars more than it is here
in the States but on the flip side the
iPhone 11 pro which is a thousand
dollars here in the States actually
costs thirteen hundred and four dollars
in India that's three hundred and four
dollars more than in the States so
they're paying a hundred and forty
dollars more in taxes compared to buying
the iPhone se so my point is that in
many other countries especially those
like India and China which have a
massive population all wanting to buy a
great smartphone the new iPhone se is
going to be much more attainable now
perhaps the most significant reason is
the corona virus outbreak with a world
economy taking a massive hit there are a
lot of people who are out of a job and
those who are still working are
definitely going to be very careful with
how they spend their cash so there will
be a lot of people choosing to buy
budget smartphones like the 400
iPhone se instead of expensive ones like
the iPhone 11 pro 1+8 pro and the galaxy
s 20 ultra and the final reason is that
there are a ton of people still using
older iPhones like the original s II and
every iPhone from the 6 up to the iPhone
8 so the question is who should upgrade
to the new se well Apple created a why
should you upgrade page which allows you
to see how your current iPhone compares
to the new se and they've included every
iPhone from the original se to the 8
plus I'd say that even someone with an
iPhone 8 should upgrade to the new se
just for the fact that you get the
amazing camera and the best smartphone
processor in the world
Apple is even giving up to a hundred and
seventy dollars trade-in value for the
iPhone 8 so it becomes a 230 dollar
upgrade and it's also a perfect upgrade
for those who don't like face ID and the
massive benefit is that it'll continue
to get new iOS updates for years and
years after today now if you're someone
with a plus sized iPhone like the iPhone
8 plus we're actually expecting Apple to
make an iPhone se plus next year with a
5.5 inch display so you should hold off
for that if you like larger phones if
you learn something new from this video
it's have the like button and click the
circle above to subscribe because we're
getting our new iPhone se very soon
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
[Music]